how are you Mars good how you do a lot
of production value that you have
supplied here yes you know I just want
to just do next level material Marv I
need to raise my game but we did just
for our television audience and I don't
know if you heard well because you were
kind of calling on time and on early and
I was late because I was chit-chatting
with Brent Musburger about the whole
sports gambling stuff that we just
played some of the old albert
achievement awards from the Dave
Letterman days I did hear it yes you
know I miss Dave so much being on here I
do catch the Netflix show which is
terrific
the one-on-one interviews but even
though there are a lot of good people on
I just miss his brand of humor and the
way he you know handles the the culture
and the political situation in general
did you ever do that with Johnny Carson
before Dave I did one Carson show which
was one of the great thrills of my of my
life and he was tremendous you know to
sit down and talk because he would I
like Dave he would and he was one of
Dave's major heroes he would just set
you up so so well and I recall the show
because it was a pretty good group on
the couch with Jerry Seinfeld Julio
Iglesias and here I come like what am I
doing here but it was it was it was
terrific and he and Ed McMahon made it
just so easy and we played some clips of
the wilds of the wacky and you know he
you know cooked a bit of better hosts he
was just just terrific and he's a big
sports fan so it was such a take for me
so you're saying if they're just to go
left to right on the couch Edie because
he went all the way to the end Jerry
Julio Marv Johnny is that the way
we call that the Burbank five it was it
was a real real throw so yeah you grew
up watching Johnny Carson two years I
even as a kid I remember going to he he
had a quiz show called who do you trust
and uh you know you could see his ad
libbing and his kinetic feel and I
remember going you know coming into the
city with my parents to go to the show
several times so I was always a major
fan of Johnny your face in the crown huh
just man and then you got on that ball
anyway I always enjoyed showing they
were wild in the wacky that you did on
David Letterman that was always a lot of
fun as for the matter at hand on the
Western Conference Finals Charles said
he thinks it's going to be warriors in
three and it's difficult to not feel
that way after watching what we watched
last night how how can you respond since
you've been there and you've seen
everything and I know you're not just a
corporate guy but how is this still a
series well you know one game doesn't
mean the series is over but there's such
a contrast between these two teams yeah
the Warriors ball movement is just so
beautiful
versus one on one with Harden and Paul
is so much dribbling houston I thought
last night was constantly trying to go
at Steph Curry because that would be the
mismatch in certain situations and they
took so much time on the clock they had
three 24-second violation within the
first half and a near fourth
well the Warriors are just you know
passing the ball around reminds of the
old Lakers Celtics the mix of the early
70s and I know Steve Kerr has a new
statistic he feels that they are
successful when they make 300 passes a
game the two playoff games that they did
lose to San Antonio and New Orleans they
had under 300 they averaged three
classes of possession and that's pretty
incredible so I would say now that with
Houston losing their home opener playoff
game for the Western Conference final it
obviously makes it a little more
different you know Steve Kerr would have
preferred that they had home court
advantage but you know now he's he's
saying and I and I believe him that he
he does like the idea this is before the
game last night of his team being
somewhat uncomfortable he I know Rick
Popovich's one of his mentor's always
felt the same way they should be
suitably uncomfortable and when you're
playing the first two games in Houston
that's the case so you know that the
guys are going to be really keyed in and
they work Durant was amazing and klay
Thompson was but yeah not not to say
that as you say you know a corporate guy
would say oh it's going to be an
annoying seven-game series III mean it
should be a memorable series but and I
don't I don't like to do predictions
because you know you just throw it out
there but III would think that Golden
State the way their style is geared they
they would have the advantage at a at a
long series Marv Albert here on the Rich
Eisen show ask him the poll question
Chris go for it yeah Marv who gives the
Warriors the best series rockets Cavs
Celtics that's an excellent question it
could still be the Rockets you know with
Harden and Paul III I don't think their
bench matches up the Golden State I
don't think Boston as good as they are
the way they're constituted right now
III don't think they could be I think
that would be since we're talking about
the mythology I would think that they
would lose to Golden State in five
Cleveland you always give a shot I don't
think they could be Golden State if it
comes to that on the finals but with
LeBron
you just don't know it's always that
factor although this is
probably the worst team that he's been
surrounded by since his earlier days in
Cleveland I mean I pray that they made
at the deadline getting the news the
four who plays I look so good the first
two games but it you know soak the pan
out but it's not doing what they thought
it would do and I know tonight they're
gonna start Tristan Thompson which I
mysteriously was not you know playing in
the earlier playoff series but I think
he will michaei big difference tonight
well in terms of in terms of what the
Warriors do and it's difficult to pick
one out of the Hamptons five if you will
that I know that Reggie C Webb are
against using that phrase just likes to
be start argument so on fire anyways
giving you slide frankly rich it's very
annoying we're gonna take a vote on him
I think before the game tomorrow as to
whether he will be able to sit with us
that'll be a good reality show up
bringing a pregame in that room but
dream on Green was what he is able to do
and how he can bring so much to this
equation a shooting and then the
irritant aspect of it we all know that
certain teams need to have what is he
best you can say what is he barking at
the refs
so often it seems like that that it
seems like a lot is being excused by the
refereeing
and some of the early games would have
been technicals ejections but I think in
the playoffs they they do pull it back a
bit I mean you could certainly have
ejected him last night or a couple of
games back he said after the game he was
to act up and I thought when I saw him
over at the bench with Steve Carr I
thought he was really actually under
control he just wanted to send a send a
message but he's the heart of the team I
mean they cannot lose him as they did a
couple of years ago
he had gone over the technical limit in
the playoffs and that's when they were
beaten like Cleveland Cavs came back
from that 3-1 deficit but he is so
important to them because he can play
center you can play forward he
complained guard he's an extremely
unusual player but he really has to
maintain his his control he knows it I
mean it's I don't know if Harden said
anything to him he may not have you know
that I guess opening minute 10 seconds
or whatever it was when he shoved him
but there was another incident where he
could have been hit with a second
technical and as I said that that's
happened before but they have to have
him on the floor last one for him last
last one for you Marv we started with a
little bit of memory lane with Letterman
and I'd love to end it with Jordan who's
with ESPN today made an announcement in
Netflix there's going to be a 10 10 hour
documentary on Jordan's end game of his
career alright and and you know the
whole conversation of Jordan versus
LeBron right now what what is for those
who were basically sit here and say
LeBrons the greatest of all time and and
and and what he's doing in this
generation is what's the one Jordan
story you would tell about his
competitive spirit and championship
quality that you saw in person to - I
guess level the generational playing
field here Michael Jordan aside from his
skills is what what stands out in the
game that stands out to me is one we did
at NBC was the flu game were in Utah
where people we knew about it before the
game so we were it was able to be weaved
into the storyline people understands
did not realize even when he was during
timeouts help to the sideline by
teammates I remember Pippen and others
carry into the sidelines and he had a
sensational game and you could see how
exhausted dehydrated he was and they you
know went on led by Michael
to defeat the Chazz that to meet
personifies in terms of his his
toughness the other thing that strikes
me he always and I know LeBron is like
this to kind of need something
motivational but Michael was you know
took it to the next level
he could be annoyed by a woman sitting
courtside at in Cleveland who might have
you know just said something innocently
and then every time he score he'd look
you know there'll be no bad language but
he'd look over at her and kind of give
her the business anything would motivate
him and he had this incredible will to
win which I know is easy to say because
every player says they have this
incredible will to win but there was
nothing like that and you know it's hard
to compare the two because they played
it in the in different eras with
different rules I think of Michael
played today his numbers would be even
higher because you don't have a hand
checking and you don't have the physical
play on you know an everyday basis so
it's tough to compare my know they took
six championships to three and all that
stuff but there's something about is a
makeup of Jordan and how much every game
meant to him not that it doesn't say
LeBron that I still think there's a
slight edge to Jordan even though what
Ron is doing now particularly at his age
and playing the kind of minutes he's
playing is just it's incredible
Marv loved the chats have a great game
too and beyond let's chat soon please
all right definitely thanks very much
guys you bet that's Marv Alberts
yes the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience